皆さんこんにちははじめ社長
ですまあ夏といえば毎年恒例にはなってる
んですけれども夏じゃない時も行くんです
けれども夏によくその心霊スポットとか
そのちょっとホラーチックな動画を撮る
ことが多くなりましてえ今年の夏もですね
ズコ物件に行ったりだとかこう心霊
スポットに行ったりだとか結構日本
各地いろんなそういうなんか霊的にやばい
と言われている場所に行って動画を何回か
撮らせていただいたんですけれど
もなんか
[音楽]
最近その現場で起きるんですよ暗夜という
自己物件なんかやばい事件があった自己
物件でももう編集とかでマジでやってない
んですよ
素なんかドンドンって誰もいないのに完全
に歩く音がし
たり
え無理無理無理無理無理ハ動物病院に行っ
た時はもう完全にああみたい人の声
聞こえる
しえ待って待無理無理無理無理無理無理
ほら声してる声してる声してる無理無理
何これ先日もね山田孝幸さんと京都の心霊
スポット行ったらマネージャーに電話した
だけののにマネージャーとは全く別の声が
いきなりうーと聞こえ
たりあもしもしあもしもしお疲れ様ですお
疲れ様です今最初うーって言いまし
た
え言ってないですよね言ってないです言っ
てないですそうですよねすいませんなんで
もないですもう
なんかあ来てるなとこれいよいよ俺多分
なんか霊感がないから霊感がないから心霊
スポットに行けてたんですけどもなんか
最近明らかに色々起きすぎてて本当にこれ
大丈夫なのかなとちょっと不安になりまし
てえ本日えお家の方に霊媒師さんを及びし
ましたそれもかなりあの長い霊媒師さん
とても有名な方であの実績もあったりね
こうなんだろうメディアとかでも活躍され
てる霊媒師さんなのでかなり実力というか
その信頼ができる方なのかなと私思って
おります夏あたりからマジで色々起きすぎ
てて怖くて本当に大丈夫なのかなんか
取り憑かれてないのかとかそういう場所に
行っていいのかをちょっと1回ね生産し
たくてちょっと今日お話ししてみたいと
思います何か分かるかもしれませんそう
いう原因が俺マジで信じてないんすよそう
いうの霊感とかてか幽霊とか心霊とかない
と思ってるから行けてるわけであってただ
ちょっとあまりに
色々起きすぎてるんで本当に大丈夫ななの
かどうかをちょっと聞いてみたいと思い
ますもうどういう方が来るんでしょう
あのおじさんとかおばさんとかねやっぱ
長年のそのキャリアを積んでる方なのかも
しれませんすごい意見のある方かもしれ
ません緊張しますではおうに呼び
ますギャルやあギャルレバさんですはい
ギャルリーバですよろしくお願いいたし
ますよろしくお願いしますレバさんはい
あのYouTubeとかで結構見させてあ
いただいておりましてはい今日よろしくお
願いしますはいよろしくお願いいたします
普段はどんなことをされてるんですかはい
普段はもうあのはいお祓いがメインでま
あとはその方のなんか状況とかはいまあの
占いに近いこともたりとかもはいしてます
のでまなんかその時の内容によってこう
変えて合わせてやらせていただいてます
なるほどなるほどえ今回ですちょっとご
相談したいことがはい僕
夏にそのYouTubeの企画ではい結構
ありえない頻度で心霊スポットとか自己
物件とかあそうですよねはい行っちゃった
んですけどええええええでそれなんで
いけるかっていうと僕霊化ないんですよ
ええええええもう何にも感じなくてそれで
なんかそのなんて言うんでしょう怖いも見
たさというかどこかで大丈夫だろうと思っ
てそういう自己物件で昔は1人で止まっ
たりしてたえええですよすごくないですか
いや結構すごいと思います1人で止ま
るっていうのがだいぶ結構すごいと思うん
ですけどでもその精神崩壊みたいな感覚が
ちょっと分かるんですけどああ怖さからっ
てこですよねえええええそうですなんです
けどそういう
なんかぶっちゃけ信じてなくていけるかな
と思って今年の夏も何回かそういう動画を
取りに行ったんですけどなんかやけに音が
鳴ったりとかする
ああえええええ見えてはないんですけどそ
物音とかえ動画ちょっと見てもらっても
いいですあ大丈夫ですなやらとかじゃなく
てマジで音がなあこれとかです
このこれは結構もう定番ですよねあの音は
やっぱり見えなくてもがない方でもこう
いう場所に行くとなんかなったとかま俗に
ラップ音はいうんうんじゃないですかこれ
はもうあの普通になんでしょう生な音と
いうか私も見てても信じますしあの普通の
方とかも見ててま違和感がない感じには
見えると思うんですよねただ私も動画拝見
させていただいててはい本当にあの遭遇し
てないっていうか見えてないんだなって
いうのはすごいわかりました中ずっとは
こう聞こえてる感じじゃないですかでも
実際やっぱりあ見えてないんだろうなって
いうのはすごいわかりましたと言いますと
はいいるってことですかいるはいるんです
ねでも全然例とはい目もあってないですし
視点もあってないので見えない体質という
かま波長頑張って合わせたいっていう
気持ちがあっても全然その本当にぴったり
合ってる時がないのでおそれはいいことな
んですかいいことはいいことですね霊感が
ないっちゃないっていうことでもあるんで
ないですないですはいなんでこうある方
ってどうしても見えなくてもあるだけで
引き寄せてしまったりついてきてしまって
自分に害がなくても近くにいる方に害が出
たりとかま取り憑かれる方とかもいるん
ですけどやっぱりそれだけないといくら
どこに行っても逆に言うと被害をこう受け
づらいので良かったなっていうところでは
ありますねなるほどとりあえず先に確認し
ておきたいんですけど
はい丈はいそうなんですあの危険性がな
いってことです
あよかった皆さん今後もお届けできそう
です大丈夫でしたなんか昔も1回霊能力者
さんにお話聞いたんですけどはいあなた
大丈夫って言われたんですよあやっぱそう
ですよねでなんか自分はその大丈夫なん
ですけどはいどっちかていうとあなたが気
をつけないといけないのはまさにまおられ
た通り周りの人とか家とかにそのな連れて
帰っちゃうことがあるからそっちを気を
つけてみたいなことは言われましたああま
そうですね一緒に行かれる方の方がうん
どちらかと言ったらやっぱりそのもらって
きてしまったりとか体調不良起こしやすい
かなとは思うのでまそういう点でもご自身
は大丈夫なんですけど周りの方がちょっと
気をつけて例えばなんかお守りを持って
一緒に同行していただくとかまあの清め
ながら同行していただくとかはいして
いただければ大丈夫かなとああちなみにえ
ギャルレーバさんはなんか感じたり見え
たりするんですかあのやっぱりなん
でしょうね霊がいないのは結構すごいと
思ったんですまあの入らせていただいた
道中の中ではこの家ってことですよねこの
そうね家の中でまあの全部拝見はしてない
んですけどこう私が歩いた道中にはい
なかったんです
よそこはあやっぱりあの持って帰ってきて
ないだと長が合わないからこそなんだなっ
ていうそのプラスな点はあるんですけど
ただその代わりあのなんでしょうクリーン
になってない部分がちょこちょこある感じ
でしたねああなるほどなるほどまちょっと
こうエネルギーダウンていうところで言う
と純粋にこう事業の流れとかが例えば
ちょっとこう安定しづらくはいはいはい
なってしまったりまそこに関わる方たちの
マインドとかうんモチベーションとかが
こうなくなったりとかそういう影響の方に
出るようなま気が落ちてるところが
ちょっと場所場所であったのでなるほどあ
それはなんとかすることってであもちろん
ですえ本当ですかはいそのポイントの場所
もあのあやっぱりっていう場所があったの
でえマジですかはいうわそれちょっと聞き
たいなちょっと見てみますかえもうすぐ
分かるもんなんですかああすぐわかります
じゃちょっとお願いしますはいはいこっち
も普段別にあれですかあ閉めてここも普段
締め切ってますねあはいもう本当にどうし
たらいいんでしょう僕のこの太陽嫌い人間
みたいなでもそういう方にやっぱりおすめ
なのはライトですライトが存在してるだけ
でもそれこそまた植物となんですけどここ
にポンってライトが存在してるだけでも
それだけでも変わりますここ開けなくて
必要なものを置けば問題ないんですよね
なるほどですねはいよむとしたらそこなん
ですよちょうどあのソファーのすみっこ
あそこかもう見るからにだってなんかあり
そうですもんねそうなんですでもいそうな
のに例はいないんでそこはすごいいい点な
んですけどもうここなんですよ
ねこっからここがそこかめちゃくちゃ
溜まってるんでライトでこっちちょっと
離れて植物とかうんうん
うんそり詰めといた方がいいですよねこう
いう空感はああそうですねもしあ詰め
られるなら詰めてまこの辺の方がいいかも
しれないですねここですねはい分かりまし
た起き
ますちなみにはいこんなこと聞くのはあれ
なんですけどいろんなYouTuber
さんとか会われたと思うんですけど
[音楽]
はい1番この人たなんか取り憑かれてんの
みたいな人っていましたあああのちょっと
ちょ純正に気になっちゃってそうです
ね道立同率な方がいるんですけどはいはい
はいあの48の円さんああはいはいはい
はいと平成フラミンゴのニコさんあニコ
さんの方なんだはい物が違うかったんです
ついてるはいはいはいただどっちも強力な
ものであもうこれ今払わないと多分もう1
ヶ月以内にはていう感じだったんですよね
何かでかいことが起きちゃうっていうマジ
すかニコさんの方は6時間半かかりました
ねお払いがえ朝方4時に終わりまし
たあでも確かにニコ
ちゃん確かになえさんのはもうなんか救命
って感じでしたね部屋全体もうじ全体に
溢れてマジすかはいなんでその思い出とま
ちょっとこう比較するとはい全然問題
なかったです全然でしたありがとうござい
ましたなんでもないですおさられた家の
その場所場所で帰るべき場所あると思うん
ですけど家自体いいってその仮想占いで
褒められた時はい結構嬉しくてああなんか
構造上その玄関はこっち向きがいいとか
多分計算されて作られてるっぽいんですよ
ねうんそうですねでやっぱ今あの風水を
含めて設計士さんと一緒に計画して作られ
てるお家とかがやっぱ多いんですねあ
やっぱそうなんだはい多少それはちょっと
考慮してるのかなっていうのは感じたので
案の定やっぱり霊っていう緊急性もなかっ
たですしお良かったはいまはじめさんの
元々のその体質っていうところでも
なおさら余計にこのいい状態が保ってたと
いうか引き寄せない霊感ですねないって
いうところなので今
あの
ワースト2聞いたんですけど逆にはいお
会いした中でこの人多分呪われねえな
みたいなああはあのまたこれも同率同率か
なって方はYouTubeの方に一緒に
撮影させていただいたゆりさんああはい
はいはいはいまちょっとYouTubeで
はないんですけどあの3代目ジェイソル
ブラザーズさんはいはいはいはいもも
やっぱりすごい覇気だったのであも
グループとしてって感じですかはいあと
個人個人すごかったので会っただけで頭が
痛くなるぐらい覇気すごい人て私初めて
だっったんですよゆりさんとかもう
ふっきれでそうですよねそうです自分でも
なんかちょっとお分かりだったみたいです
その自分はつかないつかないってはいはい
はいつく感じがしないっておっしゃってた
んですけど本当にその通りええそれはもう
覇気でしたねあのその方たがなるほどです
ねはいはじめさんはどちらかというとない
霊感がないからこそ寄せないその全く寄せ
るっていうポイントが一般の方以上にない
あじゃああの呪術回線で言うとその天王爆
のフィジカルギフテッドみたいな感じです
かねそうです分かりやすく言うとはいもう
はいなのでかなりの数をこなして心霊
スポットに行かれても問題ないでしょうね
普通だったら何ももないとはないと思い
ますあそこまで行ってああ良かった止まっ
てますし長時間いますし頻繁なのでま普
だった事故ってるとかなんか怪我をしたと
かよく聞きます一緒についてった後輩が
翌日高速で車のタヤ取れて死にかけたとか
高速道路で車止まったとかそういうのあり
ました
ねいいですかあもうどこでも開けちゃって
くださいもうこっちはえっとおこっちは
そうですねな失礼し
ます場は問題なくここもあやっぱなんか
こういうなんて言うんでしょうはい太陽
差し込んでるところて大丈夫なイメージ
あります勝手にあそうです本当にそうです
え本当ですかはい光は大事ですね逆に言う
と光が当たってない水場はうん淀み
やすかったりうんうんしますので今
ちょっと見させていただいたところは
大丈夫ですねあ良かったやっぱ私が今
ちょっと見てきた箇所でですねはいお
手洗いの気が結構淀んでますねこの部屋も
結構あの見た目が淀んでるんですけどここ
は結構結構ですね結構もやんとしてますし
あの世界一黒い塗料で部屋を真っ黒にして
みましたああここは
あのちょっと寄せつけやすくなってますね
やっぱりでしょうねはい若干湿気っぽい
ですしが多いですしであのちょっとこう
狭い空間じゃないですかなんで余計気が
こう回転しづらいっていうのもあってこの
3拍子が揃うと気が落ちるだけじゃなく
気づいたら霊が集まってしまったりとか
えっとはいこれ逆
にその壁の色とかも関係してるんですか
関係してますでですよね漆黒ってことはイ
が強いのでも光を吸収してしまうので回転
がほとんどできない状況なのでちょっと
これ時間の問題であの辺あたりにレド開い
ちゃうんじゃないかなっていうのは感じ
られましたここですえここですねだるこれ
はやっぱり壁を張り替えたりするのがまず
いいと思いますね壁張り替えるのにお勧め
してるのはもう本当にそれこそ真反対の白
ですねああはい白はあの潔白とか清めって
意味があるので完全に本当に白ですね
真っ白にしていたいばそれだけでも今より
全然流れが良くなる空間に変わりますし
白い壁にまこれはちょっとスピリチュアル
風水私のオリジナルの戦術なんですけど
ゴールドのちょっとインテリアとしてです
ね大きな画とかですね絵画を入れてパッと
飾ってもらったりとかしていただけると
清めるにプラス金ていうあの塗装してる
ものを置いていただけると金てやっぱり運
をかき集めてくれるのでうんうんうんより
華やかなもっとそういう用の木が集まり
やすく滞在しやすい部屋になるので
ちょっとお仕事に関わる道具を置いてるお
部屋とかそういうところはなるべくあの
やっぱちょっと担げるような気を入れて
あげるといいかなと思いますねなるほど
分かりましたいいですありがとうござい
ですはああのなんか一応なんでしょう神棚
的な
ああギャレさんよく気づきましたねはい
あのて動画にもしてないしええあの世にも
言ってないんですけど心霊スポット行き
過ぎてお払い行ってきましたああそれで
一応もらったものをここにですよね場所が
なくてって感じですかねどちらかというと
ここに置いた理由というかそうです
えっとあの勝手に僕こ神棚だと思ってて
ああで一応まご自身の中で決めた場所だ
からてことですよねそうそうですあんまり
良くないですかここはうんま水場
のところに直接なのでなんでしょうもっと
本当はパワーが生かされるはずなんです
けどちょっとここのバランスが合わないの
でパワーが生かされてない感じですね変え
ますそうですねちょっと変えていただい
たらより良くなると思いますはいちょっと
本当にマジですぐ変るやっぱ水場はダメな
のかそうですね逆に言うとあの神棚とか
いいものを置い直家にこう今みたいに棚が
あるわけじゃない置いてしまってると
やっぱりそのままここの水の木でこう吸収
したものをそのまま吸収してしまって守
るっていうところまでのパワーに行き届か
ないんですよね
ええ意味ないことしてたのかこれとこに
置いたらいいんですかね大体ここであれ
ですよねいつもその生活生活は基本ここの
部屋ですそうですよねそうですね今ま見
てる
と
今思いっきり黒い影見たんです
けど移動しまし
たいやいやまたまったいや本ですです勘弁
してくださいよあえスタッフさんでした
大丈夫でしたお前何やってんだちょっと
お前ちょっと邪魔だよお前何やってんだ
きようと思ったら驚かせちゃっ
たまそうですね設置が可能だったら
ちょっと難
しいかもなんですけどここかここが
厳しかったらここがいいですねここかま
作り的にちょっと可能な方がなん高いとこ
ですね棚とかでくってるですはい棚をあの
快適な棚でいいので設置していただいて
分かりましたなんかガムテープとかでこう
やって止めとくのはどうですかあそれは
ちょっとよろしくないです
ねやっぱちゃんとあの繋がった方があそう
ですよちょっと取りかけるってことそう
ですねでは
とりあえずここに置いときますはい寝室も
ちょっと見ていただきたいですはい分かり
ましたはいます
はい
あ意外と意外となんかちょっとまあの
ブラインド下ろしてるからなんでしょう
けどちょっとこ
暗いなんでしょうねこう明るいっていう
ようなインテリアカラーではないですよね
うんうんうんそうなんです僕ちょっと日光
が嫌いでしてあそうなんですね極力遮断し
てベアトを真っ暗にしてるみたいな
なるほどですね言えば本当にいいんですよ
ただ生活環境がやっぱその光を遮断して
はいクリーンにしないような環境を
それぞれちょっとそのいろんな場所で
作り上げてしまってるのでうんうんうん
うんなんかせっかくの家の気がこう
ちゃんと活力として活用できてないって
いうところと逆にいうとよじゃなくいよ
どうぞの状態にしてしまっている習慣が
多いのでうん担ぎ切れてないですね
なるほどなのでこのままだと悩むでしょう
ねあの方向性と
かなるほどはいこのやり方でこのまんまで
同じやつでいいのかなっていうのを
ちょっとぶち当たってしまうような物差し
が分からなくなってですかね目先のこれは
ちょっと運気担げてない気がしますねどう
したらいいでしょうかかもし寝て
いらっしゃらないあの時で良ければまお
部屋使ってないと思うのでその時だけは
はいあの1箇所だけでもいいんで
ブラインド開けていただいてちょっと換気
した方がいいかもしれないですねはい
わかりました
はい
おお違います違います全然違いますね全然
違いますねちょうど今の時間帯ってあの日
が登ってから14時の間が結構お清めする
のにも2倍3倍効果がある時間帯なんで
ええ今その時間帯にこれをやっていただい
てるのでよりちょっと感じやすくなねはい
えなんかシーのベッドのこういうのを変え
やっぱ暗い移っとあんまり良くないんです
かあんまり私はお勧めしてないですねま
なんかちょっとこうクリーンな状態でいた
いて方は白がいいですしま運気上げたいま
ずにもう仕事とかそういうのをあげていき
たいて方は黄あいいです黄色かはいメヤ運
とかま家庭ユっていう方はうんさ
鏡も使ってますかちなみに鏡は使ってない
ですこれは閉じましょうえ閉じるんですか
はい使ってない時は閉じて使う時だけ開い
た方がいいと思いですね分かりました鏡と
ガラスが向えわせなのではいやっぱり
ちょっと気が淀んだり最悪な場合冷凍が
開くのでここにですか
はいこれでいきましょうよしありがとう
ございますもだいぶ違いますけどね今いや
全然違います
ね明るくなった気がするはいクローゼット
です大丈夫ですかはいはいあ問題ないです
正直はい問題ないですでなおさらこう開け
て空気がここまで入ってきていただけると
はいはいはいご自身の私物もこう空気が
変わることで浄化されるんでおおなるほど
り
ますあのポケモンがちょこちょこあそうな
んですちょっとねいらっしゃってはい好き
ですねあこの子はここで大丈夫ですあ
[音楽]
たうわやっぱそっちなんだそうですね
こっち
かこれ
で1回閉じてちょっと黙々にしますここに
置くんですね
[音楽]
はいで寝室です
ねあなんか全然違いますさえもう爽やか
ですよねえでもこれオーシャンビーなの
めちゃくちゃいいけど閉めたいんですここ
のにちょっと置いてはい
[音楽]
はい
俺重力ないんだっていいってことすかもう
絶対大丈夫らしいおお良かったよかった
よかったただ周りの人とかが良くないんて
あらごめんなて彼は何か感じますかあ私
さっきあの下で見かけた時になんかすごい
あの神経労とかちょっと自立神経とかです
ねが弱て見えたんではいあの体のそう血流
とかリンパの流れとかちょっと気にかけて
こう自分で流したりほぐしたりしてって
いただかないとあの変な疲れが取れない
でしょうんなるほど多分普通のマッサージ
とかだとあんまり効きめがないないような
感じがしたのではい面前室とかはわま
ちょっと違違う意味ですね心はほぐれるか
もしれないです
ほどトイレのここが大なんですかそうなん
ですあのトイレってやっぱり気を本当に
集めてる場所で唯一神様があの居る場所な
んですね薄さみ王っていう神様が座って
いる場所なのでそちらを綺麗にしておいて
いただくとより神様の木がこう活用され
やすくなりますので配線のきを見してます
ええ
すごい私が作ったお塩ですこの塩の中にお
を削ったものとあのおみを入れて煮て干し
たもので作ってますへえ
[音楽]
はいすいませんこれちょっと今筆の髭も
ついちゃったんですけど1日だけこのまま
ちょっと今ご歩を書いたんですけど放置し
ていただいて1日経ったら拭き取って
もらって大丈夫な1日経ったら1日経っ
たらですはいありがとうございますあとは
寝室の鏡にもちょっと書いていきますね
[音楽]
はいこれも1日だったら拭いて
くださいはいちますこれは清めて清めつつ
悪いものが入らないように結界を貼って
ますわあありがとうございますはいはじめ
さんがが本当に落ち込むことって仕事が
止まることなんだと思うんですよああ
まさにそれだけが一番嫌ですねですよね
それで今気を良くするっていうことに
ちょっと徹底してますありがとうござい
ます本当
に一新来実方崩壊場103
本
新来方崩海上3
新来方
崩ま家が立った状態でもできる自というか
うんめだけじゃなくま気も上げつつ結も
貼りつつま運気を流してくっていうことを
ちょっとやらせていただきました
ありがとうございます今日は本当に
ありがとうございましもないです
ありがとうございました今日買ったことと
してははいま家で何かこう良くない場所は
今日対処していただいてあそう観葉植物と
かはい置けるとこに置いてなるべく光を
入れてあとあれですね棚を作ってはい神棚
を設置していただいてはいただあの気が
淀んでるっていうだけのポイントが少し
だけこう生じてるだけで霊もいませんでし
たし危険性もなかったですし逆に1番予備
群としてやっぱり出ていた状況がその見え
ないうちにお仕事の流れがやっぱりこう
落ちてってしまったりま皆さんのそれこそ
能率にも響いてきたりとかそういうところ
に影響が出るってところと私から初めさを
見た時に1番その部分でやっぱりこう外が
出る時って1番こう落ち込んうん
悩まれる部分だと思うのでそうなんです
なんか自分のことで悩むことあんまりなく
てそうですよねどっちかというとその周り
の人とか自分だとどうしようもない部分で
こう苦しんだりというか悩んだりすること
は多いので本当におっしゃる通りですそう
ですよねなんかお化けが怖いっていうの
ない感じがしたんですよもうそもそもお
化け怖くないっていうなので私が今日来た
時も別にそのお化けを退治してもらううっ
ていう感じよりは
なんかこう今後自分に振りかけるもので嫌
なものがあるならそれを取り除いてもらい
たいの感じがあそうですねどっちかという
とそれもありますそうですその心配もあり
ましたけどやっぱ本当にお祓い行ったのも
ちょっと
なんか自分じゃ
ないのかな一緒に行った後輩もなんか
ちょっとあんまり運良くなくてあ1回行っ
とこうかっていうので言ってそこの心配も
結構あって今日そうですよねいやいや
とんでもないですて今日はこれで取りえ
大丈夫だったってことがわかってでそう
ですねもし動画で今後多分心霊スポット
行けるってことが分かったので行くと思う
んですけどもはいはいあのなんかやばかっ
たら教えてください是非あもちろんです今
のところは大丈夫でしたあ本当ですか
なんか本当に久しぶりにというか
めちゃくちゃなんか安全というか問題ない
えそれ嬉だったんでそうなんですなんで
どっちかうと私個人でまとめるとなんかお
払いっていうよりはこう運気が上がる気を
さらに上げてくようなちょっとこう作法を
してったような感じですね今日はプラス
しかないじゃないですかでも僕呪われる
ことないってことですもんねないですねで
呪われるって大体生用からとかのが多いの
でなるほどなるほどじゃああの気をつける
べきはシデスポットとかじゃなくそういう
人の恨みを買うとかはいあの女性関係とか
はい逆恨みとかされやすいので
なるほどそこですねそれを早く気づいて
早く対処できればその分飛ばないでしょ
なるほどなるほど分かりましたじゃ女には
気をつけ
[音楽]
ます